you spoke 20 years ago 21 years ago now
at passover and said that that quote the
way the bible describes the exodus is
not the way it happened if it happened
at all
so first of all what is exodus
so what really happened exodus is the
liberation of the jews from egypt and it
is the central story of the jewish
tradition
and as i've said
numerous times um
in various places
i believe that it's based on a
historical colonel i think richard
elliott friedman may have gotten this
right in his book exodus it may have
been the levites
who left who left israel
but
historically but the bible's not a book
of history
um i don't believe that there were ten
plagues in a split c and and six hundred
thousand
men which makes about two million people
who actually if there were two million
people would stretch all the way from
israel to
[Music]
egypt alone
were liberated from egypt and my point
in that sermon was not actually to
convince people that it didn't happen
my point in that sermon was to convince
people
that the historicity of the exodus is
not the basis of the faith of the jewish
people well what does the word
historicity mean in other words the
factuality of it it can be true without
being factual so you're not supposed to
read it
as facts well i don't i don't read it as
fact i don't read it as a history book i
said look i was talking again to a
congregation that had many iranians i
said you experienced the truth of the
exodus in your own life
there was a regime that wanted to
destroy you
and
you miraculously escaped before it did
and
so a
a myth
um in
is something that may not have happened
but is always happening
and that's what i would say about the
exodus story it's not about whether
in fact there was a killing of the
firstborn
it's about does god deliver did god
deliver the jews in ancient times does
god deliver people in modern times and
that's
what the issue is and
and to me it's a
much
the issue of faith is much deeper than
the issue of fact i wouldn't look to the
torah for my science either
you